hello guys we're back we're gonna finish
Fran bow let's do this we'd have finally
finished okay yeah we're excited oh yeah
Alice in Wonderland land right okay so
what do I do with this Alice wants a
land that not too sure what to do so go
back I must have missed something that's
pretty creepy
Kamala nasty creatures excuse me is
somebody down there yes I am somebody
hey have you seen a black cats no I have
not seen a cat but I do see a black
thing eating for me oh yeah I think it's
a Kamala are you all right no not really
I don't feel very well I feel sad well I
might be able to help you I got rid of a
Kamala once all by myself
really that sounds promising I'd love to
be happy again
I'll see what I can do don't worry
have you even get rid of this little
thing
they don't know what a conch doing a hat
oh okay balloons
we got balloons right okay so how bout
we combine the water with the balloons
they're powerful water balloons and then
we can chuck it at the kamala like get
away from my house you have two more
don't miss stop missing Fran all right
last one yes I did it goodbye Wow I
don't feel sadness anymore thank you
you're very welcome
then why I'm happy you feel better I do
feel better let me give you something in
return but what is it a Twix do I need a
Twix a piece of me you can plant it if
you like thank you sir I have to give
now I must find my cat I hope you find
it see you around okay we have a twig
I'm not too sure why we need a twig well
we got one so maybe I can plug the eye I
just wanna do something with the I can i
prod your i- dharna
today oh okay
tens of those lights I got a bulb now
what oh he's I'm just collecting things
I have no idea what I'm actually doing
can I use the stick with you stick
now this is weird a golden snail let's
put it with the stick stick now to do
with this thing okay I disconnected the
machine I don't have a button to put it
in anyway so I'm not not so sure I my mg
it emerges Chad I don't have to tell you
when I cheat but Ricky I do because it's
getting hard now and I need a button for
the little was what was it called the
little machine thing I need to insert a
button and hey presto I didn't think
they might have button from closing but
you know it's quite it's quite clever
it's quite clever so let's go go put
this button in that little music box
actually I don't even know what it is it
might be music boss it's something a
mechanical box and then I'll insert a
button use brilliance so good built
bathroom monkey I'm so happy that I did
this that's not the key all right let's
take this again just kiss me neither
so you got some pliers oh maybe we can
use that to get the key out of the
skeletons mouth pliers sound like that's
what they do right that's that's what
they're used for to take things out of
awkward spaces okay let's do this
oh my guy I feel kind of bad we made him
bleed I don't know skeletons let's don't
have flesh but okay awesome we've got
we've got a key to a door
I love singing pretty close I don't
think it's the bloody door I'm guessing
that's where we go the end and there's a
little hammers waving us okay let's go
chat to mr. Vitti wait oh maybe it's not
a sister Catherine what a big cat you
look exactly like mr. midnight he does I
have to find him and for that I have to
open all the doors okay
well there's a door like on his back
that's strange
thanks kitty appreciate it [ __ ]
oh god I don't want to go
whoa excuse me tree I want the club
thank you what's in the truth still
breathe dies looks like I can go up and
down okay I'll come back don't worry I
will come back and climb inside the cap
will go inside that cat right excuse me
I really need the key hanging behind you
excuse me I just change it I sound like
that thing I want to think oh he's
lactating without anyway you know you
don't need to talk just let me take this
heat if I choose not talking to
strangers not listening it's also part
of the deal uh how disappointing I have
a question I stopped this straight I
have family attached to it why'd you ask
I'm just curious
see you later is she still talking to us
though she just says she's someone to
where she still told me I can smile she
can smell that it's the key for the door
what a 30 okay that that makes perfect
sense
let's put some water over her she's on
fire it's more
there's a soap without
crota with a stick don't you point that
shop tree on my face
put it down I'll burn you but just in
water over her it makes perfect sense
fine whatever and then come here
go inside kitty the back of the giant
cat this must be for something important
Oh coming I'll go inside it okay
what would cats want inside of them this
did I actually put that in there
why did I do that
she put him in so maybe it was right but
she didn't say anything okay
oh [ __ ] I'm putting all my stuff in
there no no no take it back so no she
seems to be a right bringing in there
usually if she does something she
doesn't want okay let's just put it all
in there and just see what happens
okay she doesn't stick in that just put
that little hand okay
interesting what does that even do why
have I done that you get this alarm
clock okay
I cut you daily wake up alarm clock oh
wait are we making everything on the
piece of paper I didn't realize I think
we are sorry that's so weird
it came out of your head awesome I
didn't even know what we were doing it
works it's so happy okay this is amazing
aaaah clock how do we use it
I'll wake up and Bucca with this yeah
how does it work
huh okay so how do I go and wake up my
bucha oh oh oh I know how to get that
thing me out of this tree do I brush her
hair but she still on fire either way
look I found a magical hair comb isn't
it great
I don't know again what is that well
it's to make your hair very pretty and
smooth would you like to try it I don't
know if dangerous it can be very
pleasant if you do a spin see all right
let's try it all right but just promise
you won't Brown me okay I don't need
burn but I'm in danger be careful
no be gentle and nothing bad will happen
okay I'll be gentle she loves it
it worked what is happening to me I've
never experienced anything like this
before but how you are a looser firm all
loosey friends I've met you this all the
time baby well thank you very much it
feels incredible I feel like I need to
fly away yay we've helped out so many
new friends with Lucifer and saviours oh
oh stick stick we finally find a purpose
for the stick oh oh yeah yeah yeah we
wake up I want to see Medusa look we'll
find out soon
we somewhat use the phone yet hey boys
facing over hearts creature from above
oh boy I want to do
Goodell did my book is dead you're not
welcome
excuse me but I'm looking for my cat I
need to wake up a pooka just my [ __ ]
mother
the Booga for you and how do you plan to
wake a rather oh way it's a tree I
thought it was a crazy the creepy black
things whatever with the crazy ideas of
car white car end is a nice clock maker
he's not crazy so you know and I assume
you have been into ancestor Howard place
I may say too dazzling it was very
dazzling actually I will give him that
this is that me why I went to go after
to find my kitty good for you your
fragile little mind will be safe there
with those boring creatures I'm going
now you wicked tree my kitty is waiting
for me let's talk to this antelope
hello goat you know it's a bit like we
are okay hello miss amore
okay right let's wake her up a big
beautiful face isn't that just the best
compliment anyone
the awakened darkness rises from the
unknown
I'm sorry to wake you up mother Moo Buca
but I need a favor from you
can somebody tell me who this creature
is quite insolent for such a tiny body
excuse me but I can answer that myself I
found Bo human girl eleven years old and
I'm very very scenic a human in my boot
of death that's amusing who brought you
here
that would be Ramon I think he's your
son isn't he
did my son manage to enter your head
already
you mean like cutting my head open I
don't think so
did you drink or eat see sort of reddish
potion all beans beans my pills are like
red beans so yeah I took a whole bottle
then I do not use violence against you
the power has been unleashed I hope you
find beneath the ground the truth that
you seek thank you but what power has
been unleashed can you tell me the power
Fran you are having this conversation
only in last episode you were selected
by five realms of essential existence to
be the keeper the Kyokai and another
that's cool
what key the five realms of essential
existence were created paranormal time
what what are you talking about the key
that the key who told you this the
grateful occurs from farming you've told
us everything a long time ago the keeper
will be hunted by the Sun of darkness
after fitting from the red field but you
are too young I must say to young indeed
to be the keeper of the game there's
something about you did something
obscure happen to you I think my mom
killed my parents mother Nabucco can you
imagine how it feels I am all of those
feelings Rambo I am all the Sinister all
the darkness you can imagine I feed from
the tears and sorrow from desperation
and fear well then you don't care if
they're more killed my parents I thought
you were nice I am curious about knowing
the reason
that makes you feel better now I
understand it's the reason itself the
truth you're seeking go on keep
perfectly be braids I love with my heart
filled oh my gosh
she literally opened her heart for us
thank you appreciate it
have a nice day hey isn't this back in
the hospital thing just very odd okay hi
oh that creatures body is made out of
baby faces yeah do I know you from
somewhere
you took something from me didn't you
thief where is my knitting needle ah did
you stab all your little friends with it
missing needle are you that the dead
nurse I saw back in the Oswald Asylum no
toilet dead to you you little beast take
a number with you and wait for your turn
in the waiting room miss NASA don't need
medical attention I just want to find my
kitty take a number and wait I won't for
me myself
don't wanna wait forever though nice
slocked but it doesn't have a keyhole
I let this music it's really upbeat for
all these kind of scary people he's been
waiting for a week
oh no I'm waiting for like a mess but I
have number two so it must be my sempre
soon oh no excuse me everyone
this is no way to make things go faster
yes become a doctor yourself that will
be faster and by doing that you could
also help us all but why won't you
become a doctor yourself then I can't
because I feel like sick I think you
because our eye is blinded wait what I
have this broken horn you see I can't be
a doctor I must be a patient
I lost my ability to fight myself well
I'm not sick at all please let me go
before you okay Fran's that's so rude I
don't even know what illness I have hmm
but how do you not know do you feel pain
somewhere that's a hard question make it
softer how can I make your questions
softer that's very strange I can't my
raised voice have you tried pulling your
eyes off it helps sometimes grows enough
is impossible to talk sense with any of
you
of course you can't make sense of it
you're not to the one that ceased or
you've only noticed for a few minutes
there's very little time certain
standards that's true but it would be
nice to use some common sense why what
does common sense do with the uncommon
sense dump well it helps to to better
understand each other we build or
understand each other around without
uncommon the stunts on your own we
actually do we expect these differences
hmm but who is the one that sees it all
then you mean boo boo boo
no I'm talking us everything it's not
the same as seeing everything now I want
to wait because talking won't make with
the weight go faster
that was yeah an odd conversation is
number one then and just switch his
ticket with mine I think maybe
okay yeah let's find out his illness if
I'm here when you come back come back
somewhere can I write my own ticket no
I'll give you my ticket only when you
find out about my illnesses you gotta
tell me the symptoms maybe I just cut
you negative that's to chat to you again
cuz you were turning us due to my bucco
idea excuse me I need your help of
course what can I do for you awesome can
you tell me what the illness the
creature who has ticket number two
suffers he's in oh he's in the waiting
room waiting hmm let me see
I see him but from what I see is not
really an illness it's just a headache
caused by low levels of agony in him Wow
is it possible to help him somehow I
need his ticket yes crying all the tears
you can cry until you fill this bottle
will do it waste fun-onion but don't
forget the tears must be caused by real
sorrow Donna there goes the onion idea
that won't be a problem
I'm in a very problematic point in my
life I thought everything was going to
be better when my kitty and I got home
but now everything's so confusing aren't
grace is totally crazy talking to her
was horrible it really trusted her I her
don't know what to do now my beuker said
that I was selected for something but
she fell asleep again I won't answer my
questions I didn't even try to talk to
her again okay
I did my kitty mr. Midnight's hugs are
the biggest comfort in my life I just
want to find him so he Hugo better
sister and be happy there you go
the tears of sorrow lovely pain so
profound awesome the bottle is now full
of your tears give it to the critter
that has your ticket to know now time
does not wait for anybody thank you that
was weird
I'm very convenient that he just had a
bottle in his pocket but I'm not
complaining because we needed that
bottle so it's all good okay have my
tears and you will feel so much better
if trying to poison in ha
how lovely let's see it tastes like the
most profound and dark it's Alex I've
ever tasted before it's my tears
give me more no leave me alone you
promised and give me the ticket if I
helped you
oh all right there you go
yes now how long do I have to wait oh
thank you your tears of taste
oh absolutely delicious freaky
get it out of here get out of here yay
bye I just pushed him to the queue hello
patient number 2 we're going to do all
we can to save you do you have an
appointment well not really you told me
to take a number and wait sorry we don't
help sick people without an appointment
but I'm not sick I lost my kitty and I
just want to find him I lost Casey don't
why that's a natural reaction of your
sickness you're lucky though many lose
their mind instead oh lucky but how do I
gain the pointman men
just call me here's my car put the
telephone number oh my god okay so I had
a ticket and now I need a phone
why can't you just make an appointment
now that would be silly because now I'm
waiting for you to call me ah all right
it's the only frown how the mobile phone
but it's okay we know where the phone is
I did I did think we needed to use that
phone at some point I don't know I'm
gonna have to try and remember the
number okay
Oh 1 2 2 1 2 1 7 2006 Oh 1 2 2 1 2 1 7
2006 Oh 1 2 2 1 2 1 7 2 3 6 Oh 1 2 2 1 1
2 1 7 - 7 6 Oh 1 2 - 1 2 1 7 oh she
holds it out well that's very convenient
I did not need to start singing a song
oh hello you told me to call to make an
appointment
it's bamboo I'm available now no no no
yeah I do have a pair of eyes
reading here okay I'll see you in a
minute then great
thank you bye absolutely pointless okay
here I am yes I have an appointment let
me check the archives oh there you are
the doctor was here in a minute just
going through the door to your right
thank you
let's go through the door to our right
I'm sorry did I scare you you look quite
pallid oh yes what a nightmare you look
like a healthy human oh thank you I
guess
now if you don't mind I have an
appointment I don't mind actually
because it's none of my business okay a
little creepy creepy guy
Oh oh he's the doctor
plot twist phase nice now you have
chosen to end your life yet isn't the
pain you feel enough you're the [ __ ]
you I haven't gotten the chance to
introduce myself ugly
sadly I cannot be seen in the third
reality for long periods of time I am
ver more the terrible Black Prince of
Darkness
I know who you are don't try to act like
nothing happened did you kill my parents
where is my cat and what did you do to
dr. doone I enjoy immensely seeing your
suffering dripping off your eyes I feed
from it
you're the manifestation of my desires I
can use you for whatever I want you are
under my power that's not true not
anymore I won't allow you to trick me
anymore
tell me why did you kill my parents why
I really hope that Fran didn't kill her
parents all that friends not actually
dead you are assuming that it was I who
did such a terrible thing I saw you that
night outside my window it must be you
who did it you trust your eyes too much
haven't you learned that human receptors
are weak your body is fragile easy to
corrupt
that she maybe Joe I was not expecting
that [ __ ] no no Terry it's it's gonna be
another mind trick no she has that
bloody knife with her felt pretty much
the whole game
who was it my darling who killed your
parents the dull little critter must
suffer and die because before coming
that star
No I still don't believe it I still
can't believe it
I haven't killed my parents I haven't
that monster wants to trick me I know
everybody is crazy around here I have to
find my kitty and leave no I don't
believe it it can't be
Hey
kitties wait what where's the doctor and
isn't that is that doctor dear nor am I
just thinking things kitty
answer me what's wrong with you Wow why
don't you talk to me mr. midnight please
don't do this to me talk to me mr.
midnight this isn't funny it's this
place isn't it you must get out of here
so you can talk to me again
I'll take you to a sister my darling put
on trust and help us I promise you
nothing will tear us apart again
Oh kitty I'll be right back
I must have dr. gin yeah it's dr. D in
dosa dear are you a right sir so wake up
what should I do to wake him up don't
know there's like a syringe here though
a syringe has red fluid inside what
could it be
blood
No
oh gosh
I don't want to pull this lever just in
case but I think I have to zapping him
maybe I use this on him
oh god I'm kind of scared she loves to
be evil I don't know if that was good
idea did it work
don't worry dr. D and it's me Fran what
I can't see very well
Fran Bowser from the Oswald asylum we
were at the cemetery remember Fran what
happened and why am I tied to a chair
what have you done I'm trying to help
you sir the big monster brought you here
we must go monsters I don't feel like
playing games all right it wasn't a
monster at all just let me help you
she's still in the asylum and she's just
this is all in her head what is she
doing here I thought you changed her ah
but I did I told you she was a hard one
to tame do you want me to get rid of her
get rid of me Aunt Grace why are you
talking like that who is this old man
how lovely you sound just like your
mother when she was young my mother do
you know her who are you is at her
grandad
I am dr. Oswald how is it I know
everything about you Fran
Oswald boom Oswald asylum yes fan the
same old man but why do you know about
my mother and my aunt well many years
ago I was studying the magnificent
samples of complexity of twin siblings
Lucia and graceful parts of my study
both helped me to find the key to
success the key hmm did you know that my
mother and father were murdered yes of
course for more did a great job and
circumference his power of manipulation
is extraordinary but what I don't
understand how he could be so calm about
it it was you holding that knife after
all I'm not harm sir I knew it was him
or all the time but why does he hunt me
the moor is the manifestation of your
weakness a blinded and powerful
manifestation of your fears
why with them wants to kill my parents
because your parents were interfering
with my work but I actually do your
favor your suffering and pain is
connected to the growth and strength ban
Oswald please let's just do what we need
to do Aunt Grace Peter be mad at me
we're family
let us go my kitty and I can find a
place to go without bothering you please
just let us go yes you're right friend
I'm sorry being so hard on you come on
let's go don't trust her I don't trust
her I don't trust her
she wouldn't just suddenly change her
mind like that listen to me
you must know dr. Oswald only once
what's best for you
when Lucia was pregnant with you he knew
you'd be a very special girl he told us
to take good care of you but your mother
betrayed us she wanted to hide you from
us she thought we wanted to kill you but
that's not true dr. Oswald really wants
to give you the best but for that you
must allow him to try a little
experiment on you and then everything
will be fine
of course but there still is one thing
we need to take care of this little
traitor must go
I freaking knew it I told her not to
trust her here was my friend you killed
my best friend you also helped kill my
parents didn't you didn't you how can
you live yourself I hate you she's gonna
kill her
stop it Fran help help please help
ah don't kill don't dare touch Christ
you little monster oh my god
oh my goodness she's totally insane
bring her to me
I'll do the experiment what she's still
warm I need to extract the brain of
right away
fana you are wait what have you done
with her she tried to kill me you were
right about friend dr. D and she was
sick she's bleeding let me take care of
her she is mine now I've been waiting
for this moment for many years looking
for the right child the right brain now
that I have her nothing can stop
everything will be fine
who are you I'm it whit the one many
children talk about
but you're not human after proactol prot
pol entres Molokai there's a flood with
Gaza in wood I found him oh my goodness
stay away from the girl leave her alone
little fan must be cured do you think
you can use the same body she's not
completely gone yet here I go her mother
murukku you took the innocent of the
child Fran is now dead and alive wake up
in darkness Fran and you'll be able to
walk towards the light
thank you
how
what happened it's what pelant was my
head hurts mr. midnight
you're alive my kitty I miss you so much
please tell me something Fran
we must go now go all right
dr. Dean look this is it verdant
Elantras I told you about them remember
I told you they were real c-can you
believe me now
oh is that what was in the vial at the
red stuff so that he kids can't hear you
I think he's into the power of Magoo
canal really must leave now
but he can come with us please he's been
really nice to me he really wants to
protect me and help me we can't bring
him with us I'm sorry but what we can do
is make him believe that all of this was
a dream he will wake up and think none
of this really happened but he won't
from a beautiful okay I guess as long as
he's safe
it's very cottage you've finally seen
beyond your own desires you're becoming
one with everything your parents would
be very proud of you you really think so
thank you but did did she kill her
parents I'm I'm so confused
did she kill her parents I don't know
and wasn't those twins that was what
we're talking about wasn't that her mum
and her like her mother and his sister
but that wasn't that also the twins that
were dead that we saw oh I'm so confused
goodbye doctor to you let's go now
friend there's much for you to see and
learn that sounds like fun
let's go kitty
I still don't know many things but one
thing I do know that between guilt and
fear
I choose happiness
look at that go
- Moo's
ppit what I gotta say that is the most
crazy game by far that I've ever played
the storyline was just absolutely out
there I don't I don't know how people
come up with such amazing storylines but
Jesus crazy just crazy there was a lot
of backstory to it you know with all the
different worlds and dimensions and the
characters and just so much dialect that
didn't even really need to be there but
it was nice because I've made you more
engrossed in the world and I really like
that about this game let me know what
you thought about the game in the
comments below and the ending do we
think that Fran killed her parents I
think she did but she was under under
the control of you know that Prince of
Darkness figure so it's kind of like he
was playing off her in a darkness and he
was her and he was controlling her and
she did kill her parents and does that
make her a bad person is she still the
hero new protagonist of the story or is
she literally just a little girl stuck
in her crazy world who did something
absolutely horrible and she can't come
to terms with it so she has to make up
all these crazy fantasies I think
there's a very deep meaning behind this
I would love to hear your thoughts
please let me know in the comments below
what you think of this game and the
ending and I can't wait to play more
games for you thank you so much for
watching me and follow me along with
Fran bow I hope you enjoyed the ride of
them through the ride but it wasn't a
ride I just hope you enjoyed have loved
a daring me by this is dark and Oh God
Jesus why did you do that to me
jump-scare happy birthday kidnapped mr.
midnight ah yay I thought you wanted to
kill mr. midnight you lied to me